a positive outlook tonight on the
pandemic from the white house u.s
president joe biden says he does not
anticipate further travel restrictions
in light of the new coronavirus variant
omicron biden addressed the nation for
the first time since omicron was
detected today and while he said the new
variant was no calls for panic he urged
americans to get vaccinated and booster
shots to protect against all variants of
covetee
the very day the world health
organization identified the new variant
i took immediate steps to restrict
travel from countries in southern africa
but while we have that travel
restrictions can slow the speed of
omnicron it cannot prevent it but here's
what it does
it gives us time it gives us time to
take more actions
to move quicker to make sure people
understand you have to get your vaccine
you have to get the shot you have to get
to get the booster if you're the sooner
or later we're going to see cases of
this new variant here in the united
states
we'll have to face this new threat just
so we face those that come before it
this variant is a cause for concern not
a cause for panic
well meanwhile countries around the
world are closing their borders in an
effort to slow the spread of this new
variant and that's despite world health
organization advice to keep borders open
and to focus on testing and tracing
japan is the latest to introduce new
restrictions banning all foreign
arrivals beginning tuesday morocco has
halted all inbound flights and israel
has closed its borders completely for
two weeks the u.s brazil australia and
indonesia are among countries to ban
travelers from southern african nations
or to impose strict quarantine measures
and partial lockdowns
dozens queue for a jab at a cape town
drive-through as south africa battles a
fresh surge in covert 19 cases
adding fuel to the fire the new variant
omicron was recently detected in the
country
since its discovery was announced
several countries have placed travel
bans on south africa and other
neighboring states
african leaders reacted with widespread
condemnation
we call upon these countries that have
imposed travel bans
on our country
and our other southern african sister
countries
to immediately
and urgently reverse their decisions
and lift the bans they have imposed
before any further damage is done on our
economies and to the livelihoods of our
people
the head of the world health
organization also opposes these travel
bans
who officials have been calling for
improved cooperation and vaccine equity
for months precisely to avoid a
situation like this
the emergence of the highly mutated
omicron variant underlines just how
perilous and precarious
our situation is
south africa and botswana should be
thanked for detecting sequencing and
reporting this variant not penalized
indeed omicron demonstrates just why the
world needs a new accord
on pandemics
our current system this
disincentivize countries
from alerting
others to threats that will inevitably
land on their shores
many eu countries are among those who've
recently issued travel bans
and with the new variant now discovered
in several european countries their
primary concern is on immunization first
and foremost highest priority is
vaccinate vaccinate vaccinate boost
boost boost as much as is possible
because this boosting or vaccination
raises the level of antibodies and
stimulates the memory cells
for covet viruses therefore this is the
police of the immune system that you are
reinforcing during that time
back in south africa the vaccination
rate is only at around 25
in other african countries it is less
than 10
some say the latest variant is the
likely result of vaccine hoarding by
rich countries because it has allowed
the virus to spread among the
unvaccinated and therefore mutate more
quickly
all right let's get the status report on
exactly what we do know so far about the
omicron variant of the corona virus my
colleague anthony howard is here in the
studio
with me and we haven't even had a week
to process news of this new variant yeah
it's been dominating
the news for days now brent so let's
take the chance to take a look at what
we know so far and let's be honest about
what we don't know so far about the
omicron variant of covid19 four bullet
points for you it appears more
contagious
than delta scientists warn that it is
highly transmissible perhaps even more
so than the delta variant itself a super
transmissible variant of the original
onto the symptoms then including
exhaustion and aches initial evidence
from south africa even though it's a
very small sample size show a high
prevalence among young people with many
feeling exhausted and having muscle
aches a hint of good news here that
we're attaching no small amount of hope
to we do not have a full data set though
yet and it may take weeks to get to the
bottom just of that one on symptoms and
how this variant works
next up it's unclear
if it's more deadly experts caution that
like with symptoms it's just too early
to judge whether it causes more severe
illnesses and deaths than other variants
do
also unclear if it is resistant to
vaccines it was one of the first
headline notes taken on this variant and
let's be honest it jumped right off the
page for everyone who's been vaccinated
that it could be resistant to vaccines
well that too it's also too soon to know
if current vaccines are totally
effective against it or if advertised
omicron is evasive to vaccines or even
partially it's just too early to call
everything we hear at this point is
anecdotal in that it's not scientific or
not yet of sufficient sample size bottom
line as much as we may want to know and
know now this variant has the full and
undivided attention of the world's
virologists but in terms of conclusive
proof brent about how exactly this works
it's not going to be days but rather
weeks before we know for sure yeah i
mean we should stick with reason there's
no reason to panic and we'll wait for
the science to catch up with the variant
anthony thank you
and for more now i'm joined by christian
lin meyer he is a spokesman with the
world health organization he joins me
tonight from geneva switzerland mr
lemire it's good to see you again
what is your take on this accusation
that
the emergence of a new variant may be
directly
um caused by this vaccine inequity that
we have on the planet
it's definitely possible that there's a
link i mean because it's exactly the
scenario we've been warning against
since the day we have vaccines available
uh that the more room we give
the virus the easier it will change will
adapt because it wants to survive it
wants to multiply
hence we will face at some stage a
mutation a variant that we can not
grasp anymore and it we're going that
direction now so yes there is a part
to that which is true
and we're hearing here in the european
union also in the united states the
message to the public get vaccinated and
get your booster shots but if you look
at south africa most south africans have
yet to get their first
shot does that mean countries that
are are suffering from a lack of
vaccines for them this new variant is
more dangerous and more dire than it is
for western countries
that's difficult to say yet because we
don't yet know the severity of this
virus of the of this variant
so omicron is not yet fully known it
looks like
it's more transmissible that's what the
preliminary evidence shows that it might
also break through immunity possibly
easier
but we again we do not yet know much
about the the variant and we do not know
whether it's more or even possibly less
severe um so we have to wait for that to
see
but yes
the more a virus spreads in a community
or a society which is less vaccinated
the higher the risk that we have more
severe cases there that we have more
people in the emergency wards and
therefore blocking up the health care
system and therefore also enabling in a
chain reaction other diseases will come
up let's not forget this is not an
isolated show and um
if one society is hit by that then again
if we come back to square one then the
virus will mutate and change and will
come back to us all so yes we need
vaccines
out there to as many people as possible
but for on your personal level if you
are offered a third shot because of your
immune immunodeficiency your immune
system is maybe requiring it and you
want to get your immune reaction up then
yes you should take it but on the
national level let's try to share as
much as vaccines as possible with those
who need it
well we have been in this pandemic now
almost two years kovacs was established
by the u.n to make sure that poorer
countries had access to the vaccines so
and it hasn't worked we're two years
into this pandemic so where where is the
failure here is it at the u.n level or
is it you know the criticism that rich
countries are hoarding vaccines i mean
who is not doing what they're supposed
to be doing
i would like to put it slightly
different kovacs works the system of
covert works it means that
when there's vaccines and or financing
available
and vaccines available then these can be
distributed to countries with lower
income which are not in a position to
purchase vaccines themselves what
doesn't work in the system is that not
enough vaccines are being made available
or countries bilaterally buy up vaccines
so that there's not enough available for
the kovac system to purchase them and to
distribute them so i'd like to make that
distinction here
but yes the situation is grave um
not enough vaccines reach the poorer or
the low and middle income countries you
know we know about this new variant
because south africa has
very good
coronavirus sequencing and transparency
also they alerted the world
what about these travel restrictions
though to southern africa is is southern
south africa being punished for
doing what it's supposed to do
yeah director general wants against
against against this uh and and you hear
also the president from south africa
voicing this and it looks a lot like it
because just because you're ringing the
alarm bell um
you should not be the
the messenger that gets killed
or beaten in this case um
but there's a lot countries can do let's
not forget that the fact that in
european airports or around the world um
in canada in the us
not yet but in canada we found cases is
simply because there was enough testing
done and surveillance done to find those
cases and this is the way to go there
are many steps so many possibilities go
uh where we can actually know what the
picture is uh and not eat a punisher
country but also if we cut flights to a
country that means a lot of things there
are many implications not only for that
particular country but we may not get
help there we may not get more evidence
from that country we may not get also
something back from that country so
it's a
we're living in a globalized world so it
everything is interconnected you cannot
isolate a problem like that that you
just point the finger at one position
and then that solves it we are all
connected in this
christian lynn meyer with the world
health organization mr lynn meyers
always we appreciate your time and your
insights tonight thank you
thank you
well here in germany the outgoing
chancellor angela merkel and her
successor olaf schultz have brought
forward a meeting with the leaders of
germany's 16 federal states to this
coming tuesday
tougher coveted 19 restrictions are
expected to top the agenda with
infection rates skyrocketing in the east
and south of the country the german
armed forces are flying patients across
the country to ease the strain on health
care teams and to find
beds in hospitals with more ability to
cope germany has confirmed three cases
now of the new omicron variant further
complicating matters the country is
already battling its fourth major wave
of infections all right let's go
straight to our political correspondence
leonie von hammerstein she is covering
that angle for us tonight good evening
to you
leone that emergency meeting now has
been brought forward more than a week
does that show the urgency and what what
can we expect to hear come out of it
yes brenda definitely shows that
governing officials here in germany have
understood the severity of the situation
whether or not we can actually expect
you know results coming out of it and
swift action and to follow that phone
call tomorrow um is another question and
it depends on a variety of factors first
of all
and whether there will be a clear
allocation of responsibilities between
germany's outgoing and outgoing
government and the incoming government
governing coalition you know because at
the moment germany is sort of in this um
leadership vacuum and it also depends on
whether germany's 16 state premiers will
agree on a common path forward something
that's been difficult in the past and
you know under germany's federal system
and the states have
significant powers to decide their own
restrictions which has led to a
situation where the country finds itself
with a patchwork of rules and just one
example from last weekend you know there
was a football game in the western city
of cologne where
it took place in front of you know a
packed stadium with 50 000 people
whereas in the eastern city of leipzig
and the game took place to empty stands
and thirdly um it depends on
a ruling that germany's highest court is
expected to issue tomorrow morning
on the legality of past lockdown
measures such as curfews and contact
restrictions and um governing officials
you know will depend on that ruling what
measures will actually be put on the
table and leona we know a military man
army major general carsten broyer is set
to lead the new emergency task force do
we know the reasoning for appointing a
military official
well it seems to be a clear recognition
that logistics um is crucial um at this
point of the pandemic you know whether
it's getting booster shots to patients
or the vaccination rollout in general or
whether it's transferring patients from
areas that have reached icu capacities
to areas in in the country that haven't
yet the german armed forces have played
a significant role in this and i
continue you know continue to play a
significant role and the nomination the
likely nomination of of general boyer
will um you know is a clear attribute to
the recognition of that importance
leonie from hammerstein with the latest
night here in berlin leonie thank you
you